all right guys
bang bang lunch money time while wall
street's trying to get rich dressed up
just trying to get our lunch money right
hopefully i can talk today because i
can't stumble over my words the whole
time
what's up beautiful intelligent plina
eva marinova pompliano
today i'm catwoman okay you do look
pretty
but we're not going to comment on the
leather jacket that you're wearing uh
don't forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by block five they've got
three products you can buy and sell
crypto on their crypto exchange
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
or you can use my favorite product i'm
an investor and a user of the product
which is an interest bearing account you
can earn up to eight point six percent a
p why in that interest bearing account
bang bang get money get paid go to block
five dot com
slash pop what's up what's up
ready i got [ __ ] to do today so we gonna
motor through this
we're gonna get this done in 13 minutes
on your schedule
yes we are all right today we are uh no
we're not okay
the fed wraps up it's two day weenie
reading
it's two days strike one it's today
meeting wednesday and is not expected to
do much beyond assuring markets it will
not
raise interest rates for years it's the
fed's last meeting before the
presidential election
and policymakers will take care to steer
clear of politics
okay so the federal reserve has a
meeting
it lasts two days they ain't gonna have
another one
and they ain't raising the rates so
there's nothing to talk about they're
literally just gonna say the same thing
they've been saying which is we're not
raising rates
of course you're not because we're in an
absolute economic disaster
and so we're gonna have a zero rate
environment for a long period of time
which means that cheap capital will
flood the market
asset prices are going to pump they're
going to go after inflation
it's going to be crazy they're not
likely to raise interest rates until
2023
this is insane but you know what wait
can i ask a question what is a dovish
recommitment mean dovish means uh
you're um uh you don't think it it's
good like like you're
you're a bad outlook it's like a bearish
bearish [ __ ] dovish bearish
it's all of them oh they use whatever
words they want all i know is that
they're literally going to flood the
market with cheap capital
and they are going to absolutely savage
people's savings by targeting this over
2
inflation yeah get hedged baby
wow the idea is the fed will now be able
to let inflation run hotter than it
previously would before taking action to
tighten policy
or raise interest rates that could give
the economy a job market
more time to improve when you hear that
they're going to let inflation run
hotter
that just means that they're going to
steal more of your wealth get into
inflation hedge assets okay what's up
yelp data shows that 60 of business
closures due to the corona virus
pandemic are now
permanent that's not good 60
yeah they released their latest economic
average report revealing business
closures across the u.s are increasing
well we knew that was going to happen
uh 23 increase since mid-july
they've got 163 000 businesses that have
said this
and permanent closures have reached 60
or sorry 60 of closed businesses will
not be used
okay so of the businesses that were
closed
60 are not reopening so it's not 60 of
all businesses in america
that was written a little weird uh but
look at the end of the day
we knew a lot of businesses were going
to close right this is
duh you literally turned off their
revenue
for months of course you're going to
kill the business
and now in six months guys and now six
months
now please gonna get mad when i say this
but just so you guys all remember what i
said
i told you it was unconstitutional that
they did it and now the courts are
ruling it's unconstitutional
google it right now uh closure
unconstitutional
the courts have ruled that this is
unconstitutional but
okay okay what's the latest one what's
the latest uh state to do this
yup wolf right there the fact that this
isn't the real publication
in pennsylvania the pennsylvania court
has ruled that the governor's order to
close businesses
and limit public gatherings was
unconstitutional
so what they did was they not only
killed your businesses they not only put
you out of work but they took your
personal freedom and your individual
rights
so okay so by the way that's fine if
there's a public health crisis
they should ask you to do it but forcing
you to do it is unknown
that was my question do you think that
if the government had told
businesses hey like there is a pandemic
please close do you think they would
have i think what they could have done
that would be a much better situation is
went to the business owners and said hey
this is a really bad situation we need
your partnership
to solve this problem can you please
come up with ways
in which you can continue to operate
your business but do it in a
safe manner so can you send your
employees home can you move online can
you do all these things
hey here's best practices we're going to
actually use government resources to
help you
start to transition to this kind of
pandemic world
there's a bunch of stuff they could have
done the laziest thing they could have
done
was just everyone shut down and again
this isn't my opinion this is
court united states courts are now are
now finding
it was unconstitutional so the u.s
district judge said the court believes
that defendants
undertook their actions in a
well-intentioned effort to protect
pennsylvanians from the virus
but even in an emergency the authority
of government is not unfettered
the liberties protected by the
constitution are not fair weather
freedoms
and placement times are good but able to
be cast aside
in times of trouble literally word for
word what i was saying earlier this year
you don't get to pick democracy and
freedom when it's convenient
it doesn't matter what's going on you
cannot step
on the liberties of the individual
because it is a slippery slope
and what they used was they used a
public health crisis
to steal more liberties and more freedom
from people
again the only reason why i care about
this is because it's the greatest
advantage that americans have
this country was built on democracy and
personal freedom
and what they did was they took that
away there's a lot of people who will
say oh that's okay because there's a
public health crisis
my point is it's not okay so you don't
get to choose there's no asterisk
in the constitution that says these all
apply except if there's a pandemic
that's not how it works so how does it
work
if um okay they already did it they
already took away the liberties
how can they like bring it back i mean
it doesn't work that way so like
in the future the government can still
do that and then the court says oh
sorry the defendant is wrong but like
well in the future i think what will
happen now
now that it's obviously there's
precedent that people will say
you're not sending me back inside in a
shelter in place because it's
unconstitutional
so it's one of these situations where uh
it just ends up setting the standard
moving forward now again
it's just this is how trends happen
right governments become more
authoritarian over time
and what we're watching is every time
there's a crisis they just steal a
little bit more a little bit more a
little bit more
again it doesn't bother me in the sense
of like i'm going to live my life
but it's very concerning that a big
portion of the population makes the
argument that it's okay to take away our
personal freedoms
because there's this virus it is a
slippery slope i agree with that
yes didn't expect you to agree with me
this will be the biggest year ever for
software ipos as coronavirus and work
from home
show value oh like like people are using
it
so four big software ipos are pricing
this week snowflake
unity software jfrog and sumo logic
palantir and asana
are coming at the end of september
snowflake is gonna be cool
yeah why is everybody talking about
snowflake uh because it's a business
that just absolutely exploded snowflake
uh so they previously had priced it like
75 to 85 a share
uh and now is it saying now it's gone up
to 100 to 110 dollars per share
it's not only the largest ipo of the
year it's the largest software
ipo ever yeah better than like raised
3.3 billion dollars
sales force the sales force public yeah
yeah it's probably no no it's
not the valuation but how big in terms
of how much capital they're raising
so 3.3 billion dollars raised that's
three times bigger than the next largest
which was vmware 2007.
they didn't even raise a billion dollars
so snowflake is literally
the first company to raise more than uh
first enterprise software company raised
more than a billion dollars on the ipo
and they raised 3.3 billion
this is nuts and good for this guy he's
built a couple of other companies the
ceo um
in the space so like good for him he's
doing exactly what he should be doing
cool
all right what's next um tick tock
very confusing bite dance
will place tick tock's global business
in a new u.s headquartered company so
it's making another company
with oracle investing as a minority
shareholder
as part of the proposal oracle will have
a stake in the whole of tick tock
and not just the us operations while by
dance the chinese group that owns the
app
will be majority shareholder of the new
entity so that makes no sense that does
not solve
anything like i said they issued an
ultimatum
either divest of the asset or we're
kicking you out
they didn't divested the asset kick them
out
see ya well he told me last night that
charlie dimlio was the biggest star on
tick tock
had an account on triller or something
just joined i saw the headline on
twitter
yeah but all i'm saying is again because
here's the problem is when you when you
issue ultimatums
like if you don't do this then we're
going to kick you out
and then people don't do it and you
don't kick them out it's like when your
parent tells you
hey if you if you do that i'm going to
spank you and you do it and they don't
spank you coming from someone who's been
spanked
yeah like look if my mom ever said if
you do that i'm going to spank you and
then i did it and she didn't spank me
i'd have done it a million times after
that right so
so the whole idea here is like we issued
an ultimatum we said if you don't do x
you're gonna get kicked out uh from the
u.s user base and
they didn't do x so why we're not
kicking them out is lost on me we'll see
what happens but
i generally i don't worry about this
situation again i worry about the
precedent that it sets for the future
situations
because this is only the start of this
whole posturing on the internet between
u.s and china you're going to be a fun
parent
what did i say it's just like just
thinking aloud no
you you would you would how do you
discipline the kids
be quiet you would use would you like
negotiate with a three-year-old
like you better not eat that ice cream
my mom would
whoop your ass if you eat that ice cream
you would use and then i eat the ice
cream get my [ __ ] because ice cream
is good
you would use tick tock as a precedent
as an example like do you know what
happened with tick tock when they didn't
obey
nah i'd just be like look all right all
right we're gonna have an agreement
we're gonna have an agreement a little
person a little person here's the
agreement
all the bad stuff you want to poop in
your pants you want to like
act all bad and stuff go do that when
your mom's around
me we gonna have an agreement go ahead
oh boy okay kim kardashian west who has
one of the biggest instagram followings
in the world
said that she would be joining other
high profile users in a protest again
against instagram's parent company
facebook and its handling of
misinformation
and hate so she's joining leonardo
dicaprio jennifer lawrence orlando bloom
carrie washington
sasha baron cohen
no it's just it's just crazy that they
think that like a one day protest
is gonna what ain't nobody care about
this
you think anybody on facebook is not
gonna keep using facebook because
some celebrities said this yeah
especially like kim kardashian they'll
be like i'm gonna
use my right wait wait so you find out
that uh
it's like less than 15 of the facebook
user bases in the united states
who don't care whatever well let's move
on look by the way they may not be wrong
but i'm just saying that like that the
it's a good gesture right if that's what
they believe
sure you have that's your right but i
just don't think it's gonna have any
real impact
i think i think the the idea is that our
fans will kind of uprise
maybe their friends they want to talk to
their friends and family no i know their
fans want to talk to their friends and
family
yeah okay a t-rex skeleton
is coming up for auction exp
expected to fetch six to eight million
dollars
a 67 million year old t-rex specimen
named stan will be auctioned off by
christie's on october 6th
you okay what oh it's gonna be on
display in the windows of christy's
rockefeller
that's right over here if you've already
gotta go check it out oh
baby what stan is one way hold on i
don't care about that stan is one of the
most famous t-rex fossils
and one of the only of about 50 ever
discovered
with most displayed museums the fossil
has been on display for years
uh at some place in south dakota why
they got it in south dakota bring it to
new york
bring it to the big time is one of the
most complete t-rex fossils ever found
has been often used as the model for
figurings and depictions
i'm not even saying that y'all can find
me on october 6th at the rockefeller
center
you've got to be kidding me it's six
million dollars to eight it could fetch
up to you
i know a couple people who might be
interested in buying this but but don't
you want it
well i just do with them they put the
money i go to so how would you share
the t-rex well they can come over to my
house and look at it whenever they want
you're not bringing a t-rex up in here
that is the last thing we need
oh would you have to come over for
dinner look at my t-rex that i have
right here
next to my instant pot yeah my t-rex
so i showed him a picture of the t-rex
you didn't even care about the picture
because that's not a good picture
it's a screenshot for a video that's why
they put it back to make you click so
you see the rest of the picture
go ahead what's next my joke the bones
wait the bones took more than 30 000
hours to carefully excavate and it was
later
installed and displayed at the institute
paleontologist if i wasn't you've never
seen who i am
if i wasn't who i am i would be a
paleontologist says the t-rex which by
the way t-rex i thought was capital t
and then capital r e-x but here they're
calling it capital t period
lower case rex paleontologist needs some
spelling i think
which would have weighed between seven
and eight tons at his peak
and showed signs of a difficult and
violent life he had a puncture in his
skull
and his ribs he suffered from a broken
neck with two of his vertebrae bounding
to
bonding together in a third immobilized
this dude was a warrior
this t-rex stan was a warrior this
dinosaur was out there doing dinosaur
things
fighting other dinosaurs by eating
little humans the last t-rex fossil to
come up for auction was in 1997
when sue also found in south dakota sold
for 8.36 million and that's back in
1997.
and so what happens with inflation it's
now i mean that's like 10 million this
is going to be
real high it's not gonna get six to
eight million dollars it's gonna be like
30 million dollars
okay just wait a consortium that
included mcdonald's and walmart
uh and walt disney world resort
purchased the fossil and donated it to
the museum in chicago
wait what walmart or uh walt disney and
mcdonald's bought a dinosaur and they
gave it to a
museum in chicago we got to go to south
dakota
whoever buys stan will get all 188 bones
in the elaborate support structure but
assembly is required ooh
i'm out i'm out i can't even do a kia
how am i gonna how am i gonna assemble a
dinosaur
188 bones christy said a buyer will be
able to work with the expert company
that assembled the fossil to take it
apart and put it back together for the
buyer
you put together a thing for me uh
188 bones literally i can't do ikea how
am i supposed to do a dinosaur that is
fair
okay let's go i got things to do i got
things to do
joke is gonna blow it if this doesn't
make you laugh i don't even know anymore
ready my girlfriend
borrowed a hundred dollars for me five
years ago and today i asked to break up
when she left she gave back the hundred
dollars exactly
i lost interest in that relationship
get it because of like inflation
because a hundred dollars five years ago
is not the same hundred dollars today
oh i get the joke it's just not funny oh
my god it's so funny
all right guys that's it for me paulina
and stan our new
t-rex that we're gonna have here no
problem that's it for lunch monday today
while while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right
see you guys tomorrow bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block 5
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find up to eight point six
percent interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends